[Musik]
so spannend war ein bundestagswahlkampf
noch nie und es liegt an ihnen beiden an
armin laschet dem unions
kanzlerkandidaten und olaf scholz dem
spd kanzlerkandidaten in neuesten
umfragen sind sie fast gleichauf und in
dieser spannenden explosiven phase
hatten wir die möglichkeit beiden
kandidaten die gleichen fragen zu
stellen über die länge ihrer antworten
haben sie selbst entschieden und wer
jetzt hier beim duell anfängt das
entscheidet diese münze
zahl ist armin laschet kopf ist olaf
scholz
armin laschet beginnt
[Musik]
herr laschet sie liegen in allen
umfragen zwei bis drei prozentpunkte
hinten warum glauben sie trotzdem dass
sie die wahl gewinnen
ich würde vorschlagen dass wir jetzt
zwei tage vor der wahl die wählerinnen
und wähler sprechen lasse mich war viel
unterwegs in den letzten wochen und
monaten
ich habe das gefühl
will dass die union eine nächste
bundesregierung anführt ich bin auch
sicher dass die mehrheit kein
rot-rot-grünes bündnis will und da geht
es jetzt in den letzten stunden darum
alle zu überzeugen dass wir für
stabilität für ein starkes deutschland
für eine starke wirtschaft kämpfen er
stolz ist entwickelt sich ein kopf an
kopf rennen so spannend war es noch nie
warum glauben sie dass sie die wahl
gewinnen
ich spüre auf den marktplätzen in
deutschland das ist ein moment um gibt
es wäre viel zustimmung haben dass sich
viele einen regierungswechsel wünschen
noch viele wünschen dass sich der
nächste bundeskanzler der bundesrepublik
deutschland werde ich werbe dafür dass
wir das anpacken was notwendig ist dafür
dass in deutschland die weichen richtig
gestellt werden mehr respekt in unserer
gesellschaft die industrielle
modernisierung und auch die frage wie
wir den menschengemachten klimawandel
aufhalten müssen ja gelöst werden und
das alles steht an bei dieser wahl und
dann gibt es eben darum dass jeder weiß
wer will dass sich der nächste kanzler
werde der macht am besten auf seine
kreuze bei der spd
[Musik]
sie sagen sie waren viel unterwegs im
ganzen land was ist für sie persönlich
was ist ihr größter wunsch für
deutschland
ich habe dieses deutschland
kennengelernt von der ostsee von der
nordsee von schleswig holstein bis
hinein in den süden nach bayern nach
baden württemberg es ist ein sehr
vielfältiges land das ist ein sehr
schönes land und es liegt in der mitte
europas und ganz europa schaut auf diese
deutsche wahl und alle wollen dass
dieses deutschland stark bleibt
wirtschaftlich stark bleibt ein land ist
dass europa miteinander verbindet und
das auch das ziel erreicht
klimaneutralität jetzt in den nächsten
jahren umzusetzen aber so dass die
arbeitsplätze erhalten werden ganz
europa bewundert uns um unsere
automobilindustrie um die chemische
industrie die stahlindustrie alles was
wir an wertschöpfung im land halten und
mein ziel ist es dass wir das auch in
zukunft sind dass wir wirtschaftlich
stark sind und weiter auch so sozial
zusammenhalten wie es deutschland immer
ausgezeichnet was ist ihr größter wunsch
für deutschland herrschen
mein größter wunsch ist dass das
zusammenleben sich ändert dass wieder
mehr respekt herr stroh den
unterschiedlichen beruflichen leistungen
und den lebensleistung der bürger und
bürger der beifall während der korona
krise für diejenigen die so viel
geleistet haben die lebensmittel
verkäuferin den paketboten die
altenpflegerin den krankenpfleger das
darf nicht nur auf die korona krise
beschränkt bleiben das muss auch nach
der krise gelten und viele dieser
bürgerinnen bürger die so schwer
arbeiten müssen die sicherheit haben
dass sie auch besser bezahlt werden da
geht es um den mindestlohn 12 euro für
diejenigen die wenig verdienen das ist
eine gehaltszahlung für zehn millionen
bürgerinnen und bürger ein stabiles
rentenniveau vio damit man weiß worauf
man sich verlassen kann mehr wohnungen
auch bezahlbare wohnungen das sind
wichtige fragen neben der frage wie wir
insgesamt das hinkriegen mit dem respekt
und mit der industriellen modernisieren
[Musik]
für viele menschen spielt corona immer
noch eine große rolle wann wird mit
ihnen wenn sie kanzler werden sollten
dann werden alle maßnahmen beendet auch
die massen pflicht
das kann man vom platz umher noch nicht
sagen das haben wir in der gesamten
corona pandemie gelernt dass alle
vorhersagen immer unter bedingungen
standen aber wenn uns das gelingt die
variante die wir jetzt haben die delta
variante zu bezwingen und wenn sich
keine neuen varianten entwickeln und
wenn sie sich noch mehr menschen impfen
lassen dafür werbe ich in diesen tagen
dann haben wir bald die chance alle
maßnahmen zu überwinden und das betrifft
natürlich jede einschränkung die wir im
moment noch hinnehmen müssen nur
vorsicht ist derzeit noch geboten aber
ich bin sehr zu lange wollen sie das
noch sagen hey laschet wie lange wollen
sie das noch sagen vorsicht ist noch
geplant also sprechen über dell tag
wurde ich so
großbritannien zum beispiel ist für sie
längst gehabt nicht so
ich würde uns empfehlen deshalb bin ich
auch so vorsichtig jetzt die herbst und
winter entwicklung abzuwarten das werden
wir in wenigen wochen sehen im moment
sind die zahlen ich weiß es für
nordrhein-westfalen sinkend in anderen
ländern wo die schulferien jetzt erst zu
ende sind steigen sie noch leicht aber
insgesamt haben wir die situation so im
griff dass wir alles tun können bald
auch die maßnahmen fallen zu lassen aber
jetzt definitiv zusagen an dem und dem
datum das ist noch etwas verfrüht ich
bin zuversichtlich aber eine west
vorsicht will ich mir in diesem moment
noch bewahren lasse jetzt sie wissen
dass ich immer jemand war sie wissen
dass ich immer jemand war der auch
geöffnet hat wenn es möglich ist wir
haben schon viele bereiche wieder
geöffnet wir haben die schulen offen wir
tun alles dass es nicht zu einem lockout
kommt aber einen letzten hauch vorsicht
den sollten wir in diesen tagen so lange
nicht alle geimpft sind noch walten
lassen wann werden mit ihnen wenn sie
kanzler werden sollten wann werden alle
corona maßnahmen beendet herr scholz
auch die masken pflicht
wir haben sehr große fortschritte
erzielt viele bürgerinnen und bürger
sind geimpft und deshalb ist ganz klar
es wird keine neuen lockdown geben wir
werden müssen auch gewährleisten dass
die schülerinnen schüler zur schule
gehen können das ist mir ganz ganz
wichtig ein paar vorsichtsmaßnahmen
werden eine zeit lang noch gelten dass
getestet wird in schulen und in
betrieben dass wir masten tragen wenn
wir bahnen und busse benutzen und dass
es auch ein paar einschränkungen gibt
dann wer ins restaurant gehen oder eine
musikveranstaltung
aber wie lange noch erschaudern wie
lange noch wie lange sein dass welt die
man sich noch mal in einen neuen look
down kommen wann fällt die mars niemand
kann das konkret vorhersagen weil die
kombination von impfen und diesen
vorsichtsmaßnahmen ist doch viel weniger
als das was wir im letzten jahr hatten
und deshalb glaube ich ist das etwas was
wir noch eine zeit lang machen müssen
aber es wird ein ende haben und wir
werden auch die zeit erleben dass wir
corona hinter uns lassen und das ist
glaube ich etwas was viele auch als gute
aussicht empfinden ich jedenfalls
empfindet das als gute aussichten wenn
sie sagen wir werden die zeit noch
erleben das beunruhigt mich so ein
bisschen als könnte das noch jahrzehnte
dauern herr scholz war samsung vor mit
diesem land sein das wir das in keinem
fall das weiß man doch und wir sind doch
sehr weit also sind über 50 millionen
bürgerinnen bürger geimpft und es wird
noch weitere geben das tun die im
fortschritte gehen zwar langsam voran
aber sie sind ja da und das schützt uns
und ich fände das schön wenn wir noch
möglichst viele überzeugen können dass
sie sich impfen lassen denn es ist gut
für ihre gesundheit und für die
gesundheit derjenigen mit denen sie
befreundet sind die sie lieben oder ihre
kolleginnen und kollegen betrieb es kann
den letzten tagen große diskussionen um
wolfgang kubicki der bei uns im
interview gesagt hat er ist auch während
der kroner zeit mal in die kneipe
gegangen weil das unsinnige regeln waren
haben sie sich eigentlich persönlich
immer an die korona regeln gehalten oder
waren sie auch in einem so genannten
prohibition scanner und haben ein bier
getrunken
nein da war ich nie
weil ich weiß dass die maßnahmen alle
ihren sinn hatten und ich habe mich auch
daran gehalten wolfgang kubicki fdp vize
und vize bundestages bundestagspräsident
hat gesagt er hat sich an unsinnige coro
coro der regel nicht gehalten er war
auch mal in der kneipe unterwegs wie
ging das ihnen haben sie auch mal
irgendwo geheimen bier getrunken
[Musik]
ich denke im augenblick vorwiegend
alkoholfreies bier und das auch nicht
geheimen sondern für jeden meistens
sichtbar ausser wenn es zuhause tue weil
ich natürlich die kraft brauche für
diesen wahlkampf finde dass es regeln
gibt die wir versuchen sollten alle
einzuhalten gerade dann wenn man
prominent ist wäre das eine gute idee
und das will ich auch gar nicht kleiner
machen als es ist
[Musik]
alle sind sich einig in diesem wahlkampf
verlangt auch wenn wir auf die situation
in afghanistan und anderen ländern
schauen dass sich eine flüchtlingskrise
wie 2015 nicht wiederholen darf wie
verhindern sie persönlich dass sich
2015 nicht wiederholt
2015 meint ja ein vielfaches 2015 main
zum einen die situation die es vor der
flüchtlingskrise gab dass wir nämlich
die hilfe in den herkunftsländern
reduziert haben und dann haben sich die
menschen erst auf den weg gemacht und
deshalb habe ich immer gesagt wir müssen
den menschen die jetzt aus afghanistan
geflohen sind in die nachbarländer
geflohen sind dort helfen damit sie gute
lebensbedingungen auch dort haben und
gar nicht erst den weiten weg auf sich
nehmen müssen und dann ist das zweite
prinzip wir müssen illegale migration
bekämpfen da brauchen wir noch mehr
europäische kooperation das können nicht
die griechen und italiener alleine
leisten da brauchen wir mehr
europäisches engagement und wenn dann
jemand europäischen boden betreten hat
dann finde ich dann müssen die die
schutzbedürftig sind gleichermaßen über
die europäische union verteilt werden
das ist noch ein mühsamer weg weil noch
nicht alle länder solidarisch sind ich
finde nur hier müssen wir mehr
solidarität lernen sie sprechen von mehr
solidarität viele menschen fragen sich
auch kann es in künftig wieder
abschiebung nach afghanistan geben sind
sie dafür
das kann man im moment nicht sagen weil
das immer von der sicherheitslage
abhängen lassen sich jetzt als was ich
den menschen fragen heute abend
ja dann muss man den menschen das sagen
das hängt von der sicherheitslage ab im
moment ist es nicht denkbar aber diese
sicherheitslage wird immer wieder
angepasst und man muss sich auch daran
erinnern dass wir bevor die taliban die
macht übernommen haben nach afghanistan
abgeschoben haben insbesondere
straftäter kriminelle die schwere
straftaten begangen haben familien sind
vorher auch nicht abgeschoben worden nur
derzeit ist eine abschiebung nach
afghanistan nicht möglich sie selbst
kennen ja die lage vor ort dort sehr
genau aber wie sich das weiter
entwickelt das muss man dann immer
lageabhängig entscheiden großes thema
für die menschen herr scholz nicht so
wirklich viel besprochen im wahlkampf
alle sind sich einig dass ich eine
flüchtlingswelle flüchtlingskrise wie
2015 nicht wiederholen darf wie
verhindern sie persönlich als kanzler
dass sich das wiederholen könnte
wir haben dass afghanistan zum beispiel
betrifft sehr klare aussagen gemacht wir
werden diejenigen unterstützen dass sie
eine sichere zuflucht finden auch bei
uns die uns geholfen haben die für
hilfsorganisation für medien wie sie und
andere gearbeitet haben für diejenigen
die politisch sehr exponiert waren
gerade frauen die sich für
gleichstellung eingesetzt haben aber
allen anderen werden wir vor allem
helfen indem wir ihnen dort
unterstützung zu sagen wo sie jetzt vor
ort auch eine sicherheit gefunden haben
in pakistan im irak dem iran in der
türkei und den ländern nördlich
afghanistans dass es die aufgabe die wir
haben kann es künftig auch wieder
abschiebungen nach afghanistan geben
wir werden immer bei allen ländern
rechtzeitig prüfen müssen ob
abschiebungen möglich sind das ist eine
frage die ganz konkret jeweils zu
bewerten ist aber abschiebung sind für
ein land des anderen schutz bietet immer
auch ein notwendiger bestandteil dieser
bereitschaft schutz zu bieten weil wenn
sich jemand nicht auf die schutz gründe
berufen kann dann muss das ja
konsequenzen haben aber vor allem gilt
es natürlich für diejenigen die hier zu
lande straftaten schwere straftaten
verwirklichen die können nicht darauf
rechnen dass sie hier bleiben können
also straftäter kann man auch nach
afghanistan abschieben
das ist etwas was von der konkreten
situation abhängt ob es geht aber wie
sehen sie die konkrete situation wir
können ja bewährten herr scholz
in der konkreten situation ist es eine
bewertung die von allen so durchgeführt
worden ist dass das gegenwärtig nicht
funktioniert aber für mich ist ganz klar
dass das keine entscheidung für alle
zeiten ist und ich finde dieses prinzip
muss auch da sein das gilt jetzt nicht
nur für dieses land und auch für viele
andere länder dass wir das immer sehr
überprüfen man wir straftaten begeht
muss seine strafe absitzen hierzulande
aber selbstverständlich gilt noch mal
ganz klar der schwere straftaten begeht
kann sich nicht darauf verlassen dass er
hier bleiben kann und das ist auch
richtig so
[Musik]
sie haben harte wochen harte monate
hinter sich wenn sie jetzt auf sonntag
schauen wie danken sie ihrer frau für
die brutalen vergangenen wochen die sie
da alle gemeinsam erlebt haben
tja da muss ich für etwas gutes
überlegen ich hatte bevor der
landtagswahl 2017 ihr damals noch einmal
einen maibaum vors haus gestellt sie hat
erst gedacht er sei für unsere tochter
gewesen hat dann gemerkt dass das
eigentlich mein dankbar für ihre
unterstützung vor der landtagswahl warum
ein maibaum nach der bundestagswahl
betreiber bisschen spät jetzt im oktober
oder september aber irgendwas schönes
wird mehr einfallen sie haben harte
monate hinter sich als kandidatin scholz
wie danken sie am sonntagabend
eigentlich ihrer frau für die
vergangenen brutalen worden
ich danke meiner frau jeden tag und ich
bin sehr dankbar dass sie mit mir
gemeinsam und dieser zeit alles getan
hat dass das gut funktioniert mit dieser
wahl kampagne und wir freuen uns jetzt
alle auf den sonntag und wollen auch
gemeinsam jubeln und ich hoffe die
bürgerinnen bürger geben uns auch dazu
die möglichkeit und geben uns geben mir
ein auftrag eine regierung zu bilden
[Musik]
was ist für sie typisch deutsch herr
laschet
ja typisch deutsch ich habe es eben ein
wenig beschrieben ist erstmal diese
vielfalt der unterschiedlichen
landschaften der unterschiedlichen
regionalen prägungen das ist anders als
in vielen zentral staaten bayern lebt
seine identität des rheinland lebt seine
identität die norddeutschen haben eigene
kulturen und traditionen sich über
jahrhunderte bewahrt und das alles
zusammen das macht deutschland aus
deshalb feiern wir ja auch den dritten
oktober unseren nationalfeiertag immer
wechselnd in einem anderen land diesmal
in sachsen anhalt auch eine alte
historische uhr städte der deutschen
geschichte und das ist das was das
emotionale ist was typisch deutsch ist
es vielleicht auch die stärke etwas zu
erfinden etwas neues voranzutreiben wir
waren nicht nur das land der dichter und
denker sondern auch das der tüftler der
erfinder wir sind technologisch bei
vielem führend auch das ist eine
deutsche tugend und die müssen wir auch
als politik immer wieder unterstützen
was ist an ihnen besonders deutschland
an mir ja ich erfülle vieles von dem ich
spreche sehr gerne die deutsche sprache
ist
das mindeste und als rhetorische solchen
kulturnation
ja aber das eine schöne sprache ich war
ja im europäischen parlament hat jeder
immer seine sprache gesprochen ich fand
immer die deutsche sprache eine sehr
schöne sprache für viele eine schwere
sprache und ja für mich ist diese
deutsche geschichte mit ihren höhen und
tiefen mit den ganz schrecklichen
kapiteln wie den holocaust aber auch die
schönen momente wie der fall der mauer
die begeisterung die wir da erlebt haben
zu solchen leidenschaften sind wir auch
in der lage aber was ist eine
charaktereigenschaft herausgefallen ist
dass die fröhlichkeit bei ihnen was es
die charaktereigenschaften der sie sagen
dass es besonders deutsch an mir
also ich weiß nicht ob fröhlichkeit nun
eine besonders deutsche tugend ist das
ist ja auch in deutschland sehr
unterschiedlich
ausgeprägt entsprechend der der
regionalen vielfalt aber ich glaube dass
man zusammenhalten will deutschland ist
ein land das immer gegensätze gehabt hat
wenn sie alleine an die reformation
denken das halbe land war katholisch das
halbe land war evangelisch dann haben
wir heute viele die mit einer anderen
kultur eingewandert sind wir haben
riesige ländliche regionen die stark
sind und städtische regionen und typisch
an mir ist dass mein ziel immer war das
alles zusammenzuhalten und zu versöhnen
denn das macht das eigentliche
deutschsein aus die gegensätze zu
vereinen zu einer gemeinsamkeit was ist
für sie typisch deutsch
da gibt es viele dinge die als typisch
deutsch empfinde aber ich weiß auch weil
ich nicht auch in anderen ländern
bewege und viele kennen das zum beispiel
unser abendbrot etwas typisch deutsches
ist gehört auch langweile dazu sie
gelten ja so ein bisschen als langweiler
ich finde deutschland ein sehr
spannendes land und es ist ein land von
dem viele andere aufdeckt und es ist ein
guter ort und ich sehe das auch so und
an ihnen persönlich was würden sie sagen
was ist ihnen persönlich besonders
deutsch
ich bin hier aufgewachsen es gibt viele
dinge die mich geprägt haben die ganze
kultur und ich empfinde mich als jemand
der deutsche ist
[Musik]
was hätten sie herr laschet im wahlkampf
anders machen müssen und was war ihr
schwerster fehler
analysieren werden wir nach sonntag
eine blöde sache war sicher das lachen
das wenige sekunden gedauert hat über
das ich mich maßlos ärgere das hat dann
lange zeit auch das netz beschäftigt und
den wahlkampf beschäftigt und
ansonsten war dieser wahlkampf anders
als alle anderen wahlkämpfe wir haben
das ganze jahr 2020 uns nur der korona
pandemie und der bekämpfung
dieses virus gewidmet wir haben dann die
flut gehabt die uns gefordert hat wir
haben afghanistan gehabt was viele
menschen in deutschland auch in tiefe
depression gestürzt hat dass wir da ein
solches desaster erlebt haben so dass
dieser wahlkampf anders war als alle
anderen und
insofern hat mir besonders gefallen der
endspurt denn jetzt merkt jeder das ist
eine richtungsentscheidung
und jeder weiß auch dass es auf jede
stimme ankommt es kann sehr sehr knapp
werden
was hätten sie im wahlkampf anders
machen müssen was war ihr schwerster
fehler
ich glaube dass wir sehr richtig
entschieden haben sehr früh zu sagen der
kanzlerkandidat der spd sein soll es ist
gut dass die bürger und bürger so lange
zeit nun schon sehen dass die spd eine
geschlossene partei weil sie natürlich
wenn sie die spd wählen denn sie weil
sie mich als kanzler haben wollen dann
auch wissen wollen ob das auch so kommt
wie sie sich das davon versprechen und
das ist glaube ich ein klar wenn ich der
nächste regierungschef werde dann wird
es auch eine politik geben die dem
entspricht fast die bürgerinnen und
bürger sich erwarten und dann geht es
natürlich auch darum dass wir einen
klaren plan für die zukunft haben wir
mehr zuversicht gewinnen können und das
finde ich sehr gut aber das ist doch mal
bei ihr möglicherweise schwersten fehler
sprechen herr scholz es gab diesen
wahlkampfspot über den engsten
vertrauten von armin laschet da wurde
kritisiert dass er ein gläubiger
katholik ist kannten sie diesen spot
[Musik]
mir ist geschildert worden dass der mit
diesem spot ist ja nur einmal ausgesandt
worden und ich kannte ihn auch nicht so
gelungen wie jeder weiß deshalb ist es
auch so dass es nicht zu weiteren
ausstrahlung gekommen ist aber kannten
sie den vorher ihre partei vorsitzender
walter borjans es geht dabei um sie ohne
mich getroffen worden ist wie sie auch
wissen und deshalb ist es ja ganz klar
dass ich als ich das mit anderen
freunden diskutiert habe mit den
gemeinsam auch zu diesem schritt
gekommen bin es ist ganz klar dass der
nicht gesendet wird und ich bin froh
dass das so war aber er scheut norbert
walter borjans hat gestern bei markus
lanz gesagt zitat wir haben diesen spot
gemeinsam betragen also war das auch
ihre entscheidungen
es ist eine entscheidung die der
kampagnenleiter getroffen hat und er hat
auch entschieden dass es dann nicht
wieder gesendet wird und das war auch
richtig so
[Musik]
sie sagen es kommt auf jede stimme an
gleichzeitig sind sie ein sehr
religiöser mensch bekennender katholik
bieten sie für ihren war sie
nein das sollte man nicht tun die
menschen werden das entscheiden und
jetzt für eine einzige sache zu beten
das halte ich nicht für angemessen
ich hoffe dass wir alle die kraft haben
die wir brauchen auch nach dem wahltag
wieder zusammenzukommen und wenn die
wahl gewonnen ist vor allem dann die
schwere aufgabe des amtes des
bundeskanzlers wahr zu nehmen
herr scholz wenn sie sich jetzt auch die
nächsten tage einstellen beten sie für
diesen sieg
[Musik]
ich finde dass es um eine sache geht die
wir als bürgerinnen und bürger in dieser
demokratie zu entscheiden haben und ich
finde es geht um eine entscheidung die
diejenigen treffen die jetzt zur
wahlurne gehen und die sind es auch die
entscheiden sollte und ich werbe und
deren zustimmung
[Musik]
können sie versprechen dass ihre
klimapolitik niemanden in deutschland
den job kosten wird
ja das muss ja unser ziel sein aber
könnt ihr das versprechen ab politik
machen die haben die arbeit ja ich tue
alles dafür
es wird strukturwandel geben aber wissen
sie so etwas nicht versprechen und
verweilen das glauben die menschen das
glauben der hintergrund kann man es
nicht drehen ich bin glaube ich die cdu
ist die einzige partei die das
jedenfalls sich zum ziel setzt
arbeitsplätze zu erhalten und
klimaneutral zu sein das ist ja schon
mal einen riesigen plus gegenüber den
wettbewerbern die nur über
klimaneutralität reden die nur über
klimaschutzmaßnahmen reden mein ganzes
bestreben und das kann ich ihnen
versprechen wird dahin gehen dass wir
alle arbeitsplätze in der stahlindustrie
in der automobilindustrie in unseren
starken industrien erhalten aber sie
klimaneutral machen dafür werde ich rund
um die uhr arbeiten und ob das gelingt
liegt an vielen faktoren mein fester
wille ist jedenfalls da das
durchzusetzen
sie sagen fester wille aber das bedeutet
es gibt ein risiko was sagen sie dann
denjenigen die ihren job wegen klima
entscheidungen verlieren
ich habe ja schon solche situationen
erlebt herren seiner als wir den kohle
ausstieg beschlossen haben bin ich am
nächsten tag mit dem chef der ig bergbau
chemie michael vassiliadis vor die
bergleute getreten im rheinischen revier
ich weiß das was das bedeutet sie 6 700
menschen sagen müssen wir werden früher
aus der kohle aussteigen oder kraftwerk
wird in absehbarer zeit geschlossen
viele müssen in den vorruhestand gehen
das ist keine angenehme situation und
auch da weiß ich nicht ob mancher grüne
mal in dieser situation gestanden hat
ich habe damals mit den gewerkschaften
zusammen denen versprochen wir tun jetzt
alles dass wir neue arbeitsplätze in die
region bringen und wer tatsächlich in
den vorruhestand muss der wirt eine
sozialverträgliche lösung finden wie
schon bei der steinkohle jetzt auch bei
der braunkohle wir müssen die soziale
frage bei diesem wandel der vor uns
liegt immer im blick haben und ansonsten
müssen wir alles tun dass die wirtschaft
und die arbeitsplätze erhalten bleiben
das industrie nicht abwandert das ist
das was ich versprechen kann dafür werde
ich kämpfen können sie versprechen dass
ihre klimapolitik niemanden in
deutschland den arbeitsplatz kostet
wir werden alles dafür tun dass
deutschland eine große phase von
investitionen erlebt und spricht auch
viel dafür denn wenn wir die erzeugung
mit von strom mit erneuerbaren quellen
mit windkraft auf hoher see an land und
mit solarenergie mit einem besseren
stromnetz voranbringen wenn die
milliardenschweren investitionen die die
stahlindustrie vorhat die
zementindustrie die chemieindustrie die
automobilindustrie und der maschinenbau
stattfinden dann führt das auch dazu
dass wir zu einer besseren zukunft
kommen und das wird arbeitsplätze
schaffen was sagen sie denen die ihren
job verlieren
es geht uns darum dass wir diese
wachstumsperspektive für deutschland
eröffnen weil wir jetzt schnell und
zügig handeln und das alle die deren
tätigkeiten durch neue tätigkeiten
ersetzt werden bei den neuen aufgaben
auch gebraucht werden das muss sein und
notfalls auch mit öffentlicher förderung
damit es für alle eine gute perspektive
gibt das muss eine sache sein die für
unser ganzes land gelingt
[Musik]
bisher ging es in den tri allen tv nicht
um außenpolitik dabei ist deutschland
eines der wichtigsten länder der freien
welt herr laschet welches land ist unser
größter freund
wer mehrere freunde unser engster freund
ist sicher frankreich weil es unseren
nachbarland ist weil wir gemeinsam die
lange geschichte von kriegen überwunden
haben und zusammen gewachsen sind in der
europäischen union unser engster
verbündeter ist die usa wir erinnern uns
an die luftbrücke an die sicherung der
freiheit berlins und auch in der
heutigen welt ist es gut einen so
starken partner zu haben
freund oder feind
china ist schon in manchem wettbewerber
auch system wettbewerber ein völlig
anderes
menschenbild was die chinesen haben wir
werden mit den chinesen
harte verhandlungen haben wir werden mit
ihnen ringen müssen sie sind
wirtschaftspartner sie sind in der
wissenschaftskooperation partner aber
freund ist etwas anderes also vereint
nein es gibt was zwischen freund und
feind es gibt
in der außenpolitik kommt es immer
darauf an und das ist kluge außenpolitik
auch mit den staaten die ein anderes
menschenbild haben wo wir eine menge zu
kritisieren haben trotzdem
gemeinsamkeiten zu suchen wenn sie den
klimaschutz beispielsweise nehmen das
wird nicht ohne china gehen als enger
partner sein müssen bei
menschenrechtsfragen sind wir gegner
weil wir andere menschen
rechtsvorstellungen in europa haben
trotzdem gilt ja man muss auch die
regime als das bezeichnet was sie sind
wladimir putin der russische
staatspräsident hat in berlin menschen
ermorden lassen nur wenige kilometer
entfernt von dort wo sie gerade stehen
im tiergarten russland ist unser feind
richtig
auch da würde ich sage also ich bin ich
sicher herr uns einmal ob uns freund
feind kategorien weiterhelfen aber das
ist meine frage habe grenzen in europa
ja aber ich es lässt sich nicht alles
auf freund oder feind also freund ist
relativ einfach freund kann man sagen
aber feind ist ein wirklich sehr starker
aber wenn eine staatspleite
stehen herr laschet menschen ermorden
lässt wenn der regime gegner ermorden
wenn das total zeigen haben
dann ist das nicht akzeptabel
grenzverschiebung in europa sind nicht
akzeptabel die annexion der krim ist
nicht akzeptabel und das wird mit
sanktionen bestraft da müssen wir klipp
und klar sein und
dennoch wird es felder geben wo man
kooperiert so ist leider außenpolitik
wir können uns die welt nicht malen wie
sie ist und ich rate davon ab in freund
feind kategorien zu denken enge freunde
muss man haben enge verbündete muss man
haben mit denen muss man auch gegenüber
autokratischen systemen auftreten
und dazu gehört sicher russland und das
was sie gerade an maßnahmen erwähnt
haben dass wir herrn navalny in der
charité das leben gerettet haben und er
danach danach in russland inhaftiert
wird ist bis zum heutigen tag
inakzeptabel und das muss man dann auch
wenn man mit russland spricht russland
sagen bisher ging es in den trierer
nicht um außenpolitik dabei ist
deutschland eines der wichtigsten länder
der freien welt welches land ist unser
größter feind erschossen
ich bin dafür dass wir versuchen
sicherheit zu gewährleisten und dazu
brauchen wir freunde bündnispartner das
sind diejenigen mit denen wir in der
nato zusammen sind das sind die
mitgliedstaaten der europäischen union
und das ganz besonders sind es die
vereinigten staaten von amerika schiene
werden verschiedene von teur 2
milliarden einwohner hat und viele viele
viele große mächte hat versuchen müssen
gemeinsame sicherheit herzustellen und
es gibt in der internationalen politik
nicht darum jeden als freund zu
betrachten sondern es geht darum dass
man ein weg findet wie die zukunft
friedlich auf der welt gewährleistet
werden kann und da muss man sehr
nüchtern sein aber gleichzeitig dafür
sorgen dass unsere interessen dabei
gewahrt bleiben china freund oder feind
ich finde dass ihre frage zu einem
falschen betrachtung der welt führt man
muss gut auskommen auch mit ländern wie
zum beispiel china auf völlig andere
weise regiert werden als wir das richtig
finden wir sind eine demokratie und das
verbindet uns zum beispiel mit den
vereinigten staaten von amerika und mit
den anderen mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union und dass wir als
demokratien zusammenhalten selbst dann
wenn wir interessengegensätze haben das
ist die aufgabe die im vordergrund
stehen
[Musik]
darf man als wahlverlierer kanzler
werden herr scholz
im augenblick sieht es ja doch sehr
danach aus als ob die spd einen großen
aufschwung nimmt gegenüber dem letzten
wahlergebnis und es ist ja doch so dass
alle umfragen das widerspiegeln was ich
spüre wenn ich auf den marktplätzen
stehe wie heute hier in köln nämlich
dass es eine große zustimmung zur spd
gibt es da bin ich sehr sicher dass wir
erfolgreich sein werden wenn sie zweiter
werden versuchen sie dann trotzdem mit
christian lindner und den grünen ein
bündnis zu form
finde gut dass sich alle möglichen
fragen stellen aber für mich stellt sich
die frage wie gelingt es jetzt dass wir
vorne landen und die umfragen geben uns
ja ein wenig auftrieb und die stimmung
der bürger und bürger auch und ich will
das nutzen jetzt jeden tag dafür zu
werden dass das auch so kommt die frage
ist was ein wahlverlierer ist wenn sie
zweiter werden hinter oder vor allem
viele situationen ja ich sag mal wenn
olaf scholz zweiter wird er wollte sich
trotzdem nicht aus da für ein
rot-rot-grünes bündnis markt carlos ist
mit ihren in deutschland machen sagt mir
die mehrheit kanzler wird man kanzler
wird man in deutschland wenn man eine
mehrheit im deutschen bundestag für
seine politik gewinnt also wenn sie
zweiter werden werden sie von hand und
mit christian lindner bei den grünen ein
jamaika bündnis zu formen wenn sie
zweiter werden würde wie vor so erstmal
erster zu werden und danach sehen wir
welche mehrheitsbildung im deutschen
bundestag möglich ist das ziel muss sein
eine unionsgeführte regierung zusammen
[Musik]
welche bild schlagzeile wünschen sie für
montag herr laschet
laschet gewinnt die bundestags verhalten
zum
abschluss herr scholz welche bild
schlagzeile wünschen sie sich für montag
die bürger und bürger haben olaf scholz
ein auftrag gegeben der nächste kanzler
der bundesrepublik deutschland zu werden
zum abschluss verlassen sie haben noch
eine chance letzte worte sozusagen an
die bild zuschauer hier zu richten was
die appel
ja mein erster appell ist gehen sie
wählen gehen sie wählen wählen sie
demokratische parteien verhindern sie
dass die extremen einfluss gewinnen auf
die deutsche politik das ist eine ganz
ganz wichtige botschaft erst mal als
demokraten und mein zweiter appell die
union hat ein programm das es möglich
macht wirtschaftlich wieder stark zu
werden sozial zusammenzuhalten und die
klimaschutzziele zu erreichen deshalb
ist da mein appell und wenn sie dann im
wahllokal sind stimmen sie für die cdu
wir werden alles dafür tun dass es gut
weitergeht in unserem land herzlichen
dank armin laschet
kanzlerkandidat der union dass sie sich
die zeit genommen haben die letzte
chance für sie herr scholz sich ganz
persönlich an die bild zuschauer zu
wenden was sind ihre worte
wenn sie wollen dass ich der nächste
kanzler werde dann geben sie ihre stimme
der spd die zweitstimme ist die kanzler
stimme das wird auch dafür sorgen dass
eine gute politik gemacht werden kann so
wie sie sie sich erwarten herzlichen
dank olaf scholz für das gespräch
herzlichen dank und einen guten abend zu
ihnen nach köln